what's up everyone we are here at e3
2016 I'm Mike McCarty and I just shred
some gnarly POW there I showed it more
northern YouTube this is Alex Newhouse
and we played steeps he recently as of
yesterday open world extreme winter
sports game I guess you could call it by
Ubisoft fantasy so we got to play about
15 minutes I think yeah about 15 minutes
and the cool thing about this game is
you got four different sports that you
can pretty much choose from wherever you
are
you got skiing snowboarding wingsuiting
and paragliding
I really like the wingsuits I think
that's it was super cool it was really
awesome to be flying through the outs
and having to dodge crags and there's
one point where you can shoot through
with like a rock hole and I failed
dramatically you actually managed to do
it but yeah so you have different spawn
points you go to this overworld map and
they're different like Peaks you start
on or just like mountain villages or
actual trick race courses Alex and I
both went up to the they like
paragliding start and the guy from
beauty soft told us not to move because
once you quit the wingsuit if you move
it all that just registers as the jump
so Alex of course turns jumps onto his
face on the platform and then rolls down
the mountains while I'm left there to
actually be good at the game skiing was
a little easier snowboarding so weird
there's definitely learning curve it's
kind of for like an open-world game
based on exploration it felt very much
like it's a technical game right and I
think the biggest problem we both had
with it was the controls the controls
are meant to be more simulation than
arcade so don't think SSX tricky and so
with snowboarding the jumps are on the
triggers and you also have to tap the
triggers to spin so it's a little it was
hard to get used to yeah and you can go
like with the first-person GoPro yeah by
tapping lb which I didn't know until I
was halfway through his jump smash my
face but also yeah it's you know like
it's kind of Eddie makuu our news editor
also sorry he really liked it but he was
the one he kept used to the controls
little earlier on than we did I think me
and you were kind of more in just in the
open-world aspects because you know the
game Forza horizon 3 which is also
announced
at the show and that's kind of the same
lore of the open world just exploring
like with driving in that case in this
case just like flying down the slopes
and everything definite learning curve
but I feel like once you get through it
that game could be fun
yeah and they even gave us the option to
do races and I'm like no I didn't want
to do that I just kind of roamed around
the mountain doing like switching
between skiing and snowboarding and
trying to do wingsuiting trying and
failing spectacularly to do paragliding
but I actually thought that the first
person thing was supercool because it it
felt a little more like the controls
made sense from that view but yeah I
think it has a lot of promise yeah so
they're telling us that was just like a
small part of the overall map it was
still pretty sizable but you know you
could just roam around if you want to
which is the most appealing aspect to me
and maybe you too but anyway so yeah
that was steep that releases December of
this year from VB saw Santa si for more
news about that I'm sure we'll have a
write-up coming up and for more news
from III 2016 stay tuned to game spot